My name is Joanne Cheung and I am a graduate
student in the Harvard Graduate School of
Design.
I’m a fellow at Berkman this year, I’m
an artist, and an architect.
This year I’m developing an analytical framework
for looking at public space, so physical space,
all the stuff around us, and discourse on
the internet.
My background is in the fine arts, so I’ve
always cared about how to communicate something,
how something appears to someone not from
my own discipline.
A lot of this came from, well, I guess two
things.
One is the very jarring experience of the
past election and realizing that geographically,
my understanding of the country that I live
in is very different than what I thought it
was.
Also, this summer I became an American citizen,
so learning everything about the democratic
process was really interesting, and I thought
that I wanted to understand how my own discipline
intersected with the political process.
There is no opting out of existing in this
system and I think now that everyone is so
deeply connected, the other side of that is
we’re all more alienated from the subjects
of our actions, so whether they’re intentional,
unintentional, or accidental, I think making
those connections visible is really important
now.
Of course I always go back to that William
Gibson quote, “the future is already here,
it’s just not evenly distributed,” but
then I go back and think about my own discipline,
which is dealing with land and buildings,
and I was thinking, well, the future doesn’t
distribute itself, has land ever been evenly
distributed?
I can’t think of something that has.
A lot of that comes down to human agency,
it comes down to decisions humans make.
I think it’s not technology doing the work,
it’s people doing the work, and so, maybe
that gives me some worry, it scares me because
I want to define who those humans are, but
it also gives me a little bit of hope because
I’m a human, we all are, so there is potential
for making change and making a difference.